je le vois à l'accueil d'un club
libertin lien alors une fois ce qui a
déjà été dans un club libertin les abats
à
cheryl rihanna lady gilles oui parce que
j'avais fait une enquête sur eux
une enquête oui sur dominique strauss
kahn les lieux où ils allaient ah je
suis allé dans tous les lieux ah oui
notamment un j'ai fait une enquête sur
dominique chapatte et où les gardes
alors et notamment un où j'ai été vendus
comme esclaves non oui ah bah ils n'ont
pas dû payer cher
voir moi ce que j'aime c'est les noms de
comme libertin ils sont toujours très
forts il ya le de +2 parce qu'en fait
vous arrivez vous êtes 2 qui après vous
être plus de il ya le nom mia le touche
à tout âge à toi c'est
vrai non mais franchement il ya le
cléopâtre vous les connaissez
pas laisser sa journée à vous renvoyer
la question mais quoi qu est ce qu a
rien de jalel ben alors qu'est ce qu'il
a laissé aller dans un club libertin
alors je vous dire jamais mais mais
forcément chez enquêté pour elle un
commentateur
non je suis jamais allé bref alors
valbuena il me connaît voilà la bande
domain jovien un truc il m'est arrivé un
truc de fou mais même alors elle m'a dit
je peux pas de ce qui s'est passé mais
un jour
19 ans maintenant je ne fais pas du tout
de télé et je suis allé dans un club
libertin pour rigoler on a peur on
n'avait rien fait on dit avec des
copains ça on a été prendre un verre et
j'ai vu un animateur très très très
court
que c'est vrai dawn est la première à
posséder leur silence et il est encore à
l'antenne impossible à la reprise
[Applaudissements]
moi je faisais pas tu es donc il savait
pas mais voilà la presse alors y'a pas
il y en a plusieurs qui sont encore à
l'antenne n'est qu' on prétendrait plein
hiver sont exactement à quelqu'un dont
on ne soupçonne un jour à la maison
je ne sais pas michel drucker au meurtre
amie marianne c'est mon frère non non
non c'est un sénateur ou journalisme et
on coule ou
non non non mais je vous dise oui oui ce
qui a déjà dénoncé passe-partout
sais pas non non il y avait non il y
avait le père fourreur
non non pas du tout non je veux plus
entendre ça castany vous une fois
j'étais dans ma vie ah oui je sais ça
servait le bouche à oreille a le bouche
à oreille est en fait celle du nil et
non ce qu'ils ont prévu une salle bach
c'était vraiment un club libertin le
bouche à oreille bonjour c'est ça
jusqu'à trois heures tout est normal
mais tout est normal les gens sont
sympathiques voilà et à 3 heures une
ouais il ya le bouche à oreille tout
l'état pôle nord 12 heures salamé les
gens sont très gentils alors très sympa
moi je suis parent à paris parce qu'il y
avait un monsieur qui se rapprochait de
moi donc je lui dis ce soir
d sinon
c'est très particulier
c'est une question assez parce qu'il a
commencé en disant qu'ils avaient été
esclaves
je crois que ça s'appelle cris et
chuchotements
christ a paris encore et donc il fallait
choisir quelqu'un qu'on vendait comme
esclaves et que des gens à acheter
évidemment c'est tombé sur moi ah ouais
donc
être est on sûr vintage lorit simon
s'est monté très haut oui pour vous si
vous déployez oui oui de plus 10 euros
j'ai été acheté mais vu ce qu'on me
proposait comme peine j'ai renoncé à un
certain moment sans être vus hier la
peine était quoi je commençais à monter
nu des escaliers c'est derrière moi
ça va vous si donc
oui c'est vrai oui ça quoi en tant que
balance numéro de cette émission oui je
suis en train de voir laurence avec ses
petits regards coquins et je pense que
oui moi aussi j'ai déjà je pense que
leur enseigner inattendu parle avant
d'être porte parole des républicains je
pense que l'un des porte parole du
touche-à-tout
[Applaudissements]
face à travailler à à ne pas tout mettre
au boulot alors laurent ça y est oui la
vérité haute à ce mouvement à toute
norme tatum et touche à tout mais tous
fruits ça va vous sinon
je devais sur ces nous ça va alors l
artiste a tout fait mais tout va
changer ça change dites moi alors je
connais pas tu as tout maintenant est ce
que vous avez déjà été dans un club
libertin bien sûr que non je te la
vérité lors elle est où la vérité vous
connaissez si l'on faisait déjà menti si
oui oui ah bon ça y est ça l exemple ban
acheter